well yes first of all thanks to the
organizers for the invitation I'm Sandra
and what I want to talk about today is
large-scale coordination and networks
and after a short preamble I'm going to
focus on a paper that i published
recently with a team of physicists /
computer scientists that i think will
help me put on the table a few topics
for discussion that i think fit well the
theme of this meeting now I'm a
sociologist by training all my degrees
are in sociology but I work in a
communication in school and that is not
a coincidence I think it's pretty
obvious that communication technologies
mediated a most dimensions of social
life and so I think that if we want to
untangle the logic of social life and
this is what we sociology is like doing
that we need to understand the logic of
communication in the dynamics that
communication triggers and so my work so
far has focused mostly on the emergence
of coordination in decentralized
networks and you have two pictures here
one is about fireflies flashing
beautifully at the same time the other
is about protesters in Hong Kong during
the so-called umbrella revolution which
took place in 2014 as you all know
fireflies and protesters are very
different types of living creatures but
they share one thing and that is the
ability to coordinate in a decent
relized way and that is determine to a
great extent by communication networks
in the case of protesters social media
seem to have played an instrumental role
in helping them coordinate their actions
and yes there has been a lot of shallow
commentary on the value of Twitter
revolutions but to me one obvious piece
of evidence suggesting that social media
is important are all the attempts by
governments around the world to control
information flow in those platforms in
the form of censorship or direct pruning
as in arresting people so a lot of my
work tries to find out in what sense
social media and more generally the
centralized communication networks
mediate the process of large-scale
coordination in
in the paper that I want to discuss
today is an attempt to do that using
Twitter data however as a sociologist
with the weakness for history I can't
help but take us back a couple of
centuries so that we can revisit an
earlier communication revolution to the
one that we have today and that was a
revolution triggered by the invention of
the Telegraph which commentators of the
time called the wonder of the age and
which more recently has been referred to
as the Victorian Internet and the reason
is because the reactions to the
Telegraph were not that different from
our reactions to digital technologies
today one thing that surprises me when
looking at these historical accounts is
that we use the same metaphors or the
same mental maps as you call them to
talk about these communication
technologies now two centuries before
IBM talked about the Internet of Things
as the nervous system of the planetary
body Engineers referred to the Telegraph
as the nervous system of the commercial
system and so in both instances the
analogy pushes you to think that if the
reason there was two standard surely we
need a brain processing all that
information in a centralized way and I'm
not sure that that is necessarily the
best way to think about it in any case
the invention of the telegraph was part
of bigger social transformations amongst
them the Wrekin figuration of knowledge
so that universities could start giving
space to emerging sciences like
engineering but also sociology and I
think that perhaps today we are in a
similar crossroads as back then in terms
of redefining those boundaries and so in
the history of social father is this big
debate that took place at the end of the
19th century between two of the founders
of sociological thinking Emile Durkheim
and Gabrielle tarde the sociologists in
the room will recognize these for the
non sociologists take this as a crash
course and social thought and a promise
I'll be brief so essentially the reason
why these two gentlemen disagreed was
because they had very different answers
to a seemingly simple question and that
is what our social facts now the answer
to his question was very important
because it was to define the boundaries
of these emerging discipline called
sociology so the answer the dark I'm
Gates gave was social facts are social
structures so all those group divisions
that transcend specific individuals
right so when you think about it Nyssa t
when you think about social class these
are the important explanatory factors
that dark I'm hot in mine when talking
about social facts now the answer that
Todd gave to this question was very
different for him the elemental social
fact was in attention which is a term
that he used to talk about contagion and
social influence as channeled by
communication so for him communication
was the quintessential social fact in
the main driver of social change
according to all accounts dark I'm won
this debate but this wasn't necessarily
because he had the best ideas he had
received the support of the university
system which created the first sociology
chair for him while Todd was still an
outsider and he was also cleverly
exploiting the best data that was
available at a time which was
essentially census data Todd on the
other hand was interested in things that
couldn't be unambiguously measured back
then but which he thought were becoming
increasingly important due to the
expansion of communication technologies
like the Telegraph and so it was Todd's
ideas were transported across the
Atlantic to start the line of research
known as collective behavior which is
where my interest in coordination would
feed this is a very brief historical
timeline of these branch of research
that sociology is like a luke adds
define us dynamics that break away from
social structures such as class
ethnicity or bureaucracy which are the
sort of things that many sociologists
are interested in but not me or not in
the first instance and so the subject
matter for this line of work included
things as diverse as crowds fats fashion
rumours opinion formation social unrest
and social movements there was one
common denominator for all these authors
that was their emphasis on the
importance of interdependence and what
they call social contagion again
following a common metaphor in the 18th
in the 19th centuries when societies
were compared to living organisms which
is by the way the same metaphor that the
IBM's of the world used today when they
talk about global brains and planetary
nervous systems in any case and I'm
getting closer to the point that I want
to make those following this line of
research were constantly struggling with
the lack of appropriate data right the
closest start ever go to measuring his
ideas and social contagion was when he
fantasized about compiling statistics of
conversation as he called it he wrote
much in the same way in which we can
measure the walking speed of pedestrians
in various capitals of the world so we
could try to measure the speed of
conversation in each city as well in
this matter because talking was in his
scheme of things one of the main ways in
which ideas get transmitted from person
to person and so you know the more
conversations you have the more
opportunities for contagion however he
concluded the elements for the moment
are lacking by which he meant that that
sort of data were still not available
later in the 50s some sociologists Road
collective behavior is not yet an area
in which generalizations can be
presented in precise form and with the
backing of experimental quantitative
evidence and in the 60s some other
sociologists road because of the
magnitude and complexity collective
phenomena are not directly a mineral to
observation under the kind of rigorously
control conditions most sociologists
would choose they also pointed out that
collective behavior is by definition
spontaneous and unpredictable and so
that was the main reason they argued why
it is so difficult to analyze and then
in the 70s things start changing a
little with the first mathematical
models that at least offered the
possibility of conducting more
sophisticated for experiments but again
those developments were limited by the
fact that they could not be validated
with empirical data and this is what
digital technology's a stankin was
saying this morning and a few of us
most of you know who this is what
digital technologies have changed all
right so to summarize digital
technologies have made miserable what
back in the 19th century was so
difficult to grasp which is essentially
I would argue is the main reason why its
heart lost his debate and they have
placed the analyses of spontaneous and
unstructured social action back at the
heart of research helping us overcome
many of the difficulties encountered by
sociologists decades ago the difference
and this is an important difference is
that insides are now coming not just
from the social sciences with their
historical boundaries but from the many
attempts to analyze the new available
evidence with a multidisciplinary
mindset and I think that all of us here
know what that means anything that we
all agree that this is a good is a good
thing to encourage that way of thinking
the way I said there are three main
areas of work that define the field of
collective behavior today the first is
the study of aggregated patterns of
collective attention with a focus on
temporal dynamics the second refers to
the analysis of networks of information
flow with a focus on the structural
properties of those networks and the
third refers to the individual level
mechanisms that make those other higher
level dynamics emerge a many of us in
this room have worked in one way or
another in these three dimensions the
one I want to focus on today is this
aggregated patterns of collective
attention because i think that they
reveal interesting things about
large-scale coordination okay and so
this is the paper that i want to discuss
it was published earlier this month and
this is the dream team of physicists who
are each unique in the background but
they all share an interest in networks
and social systems in spite of the
somehow cryptic title and I really tried
to change it but they didn't let me all
we try to do in this paper is determine
who leads and who follows in
communication networks when massive
collective events take place and that
includes protests and political
mobilizations
and so following the problem-solving
spirit of which Duncan was talking this
morning there are two problems we dealt
with in this paper one we could solve
and the other we couldn't although we
already knew when we started these that
we wouldn't be able to solve it and yet
somehow we still have hopes that we will
be able to do it at some point the
problem we could solve relates to
finding the appropriate and portal scale
to analyze communication dynamics this
question derives from increasing
empirical evidence suggesting that human
communication doesn't follow the
patterns depicted in panel a meaning the
rate at which information is being
exchanged is not constant over time but
instead it exhibits this sort of
birthday profile of panel be there are
periods of intense communication
activity and periods where nothing seems
to happen and these goes beyond the
usual circadian cycles right and
communication collected around political
protests and social mobilization
certainly follows the second pattern and
so the question here in this matter is
obviously because if communication
channel social influence what this means
is that influence will be more intense
specific periods of time and it's not
necessarily easy a priority to determine
when that will happen and so the
question here is how do we adjust our
lenses when examining this dynamic so
that we capture the intrinsic rhythm of
communication and so that we can zoom in
when we need to and we can zoom out when
we have to now the question we couldn't
answer is where the changes in the
characteristic temporal scale can help
us predict collective events like
massive mobilizations or trending topics
before they are trending the idea here
is that we could in principle use this
metric of how fast or how slowly
information is being exchanged online as
we would use voice in the sea namely as
a mechanism to determine when the waters
are rising before the tsunami strikes
and this picture on the screen is a
kinetic sculpture but they'd be boring
that I saw ones that moves by
doing real-time information from a boy
that is hidden in some sporting the
ocean and I thought it was pretty
awesome but it was like a window to this
part of the world that we will never see
em physically but anyway the methodology
that we introduced in this paper which
i'm going to explain to you in a minute
gives us a metric that in principle we
could use for these but that in practice
only works with the benefit of hindsight
because you need to know which tweets to
look for essentially and when you don't
know when you're what you're looking for
the method doesn't work and so let me
tell you a little bit more about the
method so this figure here is a
schematic summary of the steps involved
in our methodology the first thing we do
is to use a geographical partition to
reconstruct the time series tracking
activity patterns in Twitter so that
will be panel a this time series contain
information about the role that each
geographic area plays in shaping overall
communication dynamics and so in this
example the geographic areas correspond
to entire countries but we could also
aggregate information on a lower
resolution level for instance cities and
in fact for most of the data that we
analyze we use the level of metropolitan
regions or for conceptually different
partitions for instance social
demographic groups whatever the
partition used with the technique tries
to do is determine who leads and who
follows in the exchange of information
that is whether activity in one region
helps predict activity in another region
and so the technique does is the first
transform the time series into a shorter
sequence of symbols that simplifies the
complexity of the original signal that
would be depicted in panel B you should
think of these sequence of symbols as a
sort of DNA encoding the profile of
communication dynamics that we can then
use to find patterns of directional
influence and the goal here is very
similar to that of Granger causality but
the symbolic transformation is important
in this context because it helps us
control for the amplitude of each time
series and it
eliminates the impact that more densely
populated regions have an overall volume
you know more social media users
trivially lead to more messages and
higher spikes and so by transforming
spiky and non-stationary series into a
sequence of symbols that only map the
apps and downs of the trends so to speak
and not the magnitude the method
eliminates noise and helps identify more
clearly the driving dynamics across
regions and so these driving dynamics
can then be represented as a network
mapping the influence that each region
has over the other regions and so when a
time series helps predict another time
series it means that there is a transfer
of information from the first geographic
region to the second in other words that
the second region is following the first
and so essentially what the method helps
answer is the question of whether some
regions where there are some regions
that bleep the way when it comes to
drawing attention to some issues all
right but now this is where we enter the
domain of the first problem that I
mentioned and that is how to find the
right scale to build a time series and
by this I mean that if you use a wider
aggregation sponse if you pull together
activity over a month instead of say a
day that will result in fewer data
points and smoother trends and if you
use narrower spans then the series will
have more points but spike your and
noise your signals and that's what
policy aims to illustrate as a question
here is which standpoint of resolution
do we use to aggregate the data let me
say here that the sociologist the
problem of scale is a sort of question
that wasn't even in the radar for my
social research before digital data
became overwhelmingly available most
communication activity today can be
obtained with a temporal resolution that
goes down to the second so the question
is again how much do we need to adjust
our zoom lenses if these were camera to
capture the action as it unfolds and
what this means is that we have defined
a way of aggregating temporal data so
that we can reveal significant patterns
in an ocarina in our case who's leading
a process of collective upheaval and
who's following to make it grow and this
is what would make use of a data-driven
solution which is essentially possible
because of the computational tools that
we have now our disposal and also
because of the magic of my colleague
hard worker who did all the computations
but the solution entail the following
for a given sliding window consider all
possible pairs of geographical units in
this example countries and compute the
total amount of information being
transferred between them for different
aggregation span say a minute an hour a
day the amount of information
transferred as calculated by this
symbolic transfer entropy measure that
gives title to the paper that is the
metric that serves as a proxy or that we
use as a proxy for Lee the follower
dynamics right so the higher the total
transfer of information amongst regions
that is the stronger the ties in the
network depicted in panel B the more
leading following trends are revealed by
the data so this metric which is the one
that we use above is probably other
metrics that could be used for the same
purpose changes depending on how we
allocate the time series so we use
different aggregation rules we can then
compare how the metric varies for each
of those rules and then select the
aggregation span that maximizes
information flow in this is we are you
and I guess this is the main argument
that we make in the paper this is a
temporal scale that best captures the
intrinsic rhythm of the centralized
communication the aggregation span that
maximizes information flow across
regions and so what the method and
wheels and I'm going to show you some of
the empirical data in a minute is that
this rhythm is not constant it
progressively gets smaller as the onset
of massive collective events for
instance a social mobilization gets
closer right and so that would be
captured by panel da however this is
only the case when the momentum is build
up and dodgin ously from the bottom up
in cases where what we call collective
effervescence to honor dark i'm when
those moments of collective
effervescence results from mass media
interventions
so that would be like an exogenous shock
in the form of breaking news then the
characteristic temporal scale remains
stable until the news break in which
brings it suddenly down by accelerating
interest and the pace at which
communication flows and this is the
scenario that we try to depict in panel
TV and so overall the method shows that
the temporal scale of communication
decreases systematically as the levels
of global and internal coordination
increase that is as a different time
series start synchronizing with each
other and what this means is that social
influence ends up aligning all the time
series to the same tempo which in turn
means that all regions are sort of
boiling at the same time and it's not
possible to identify leaders of
followers so clearly anymore and again
this build-up process is not visible
when an external force say mass media
suddenly drives collective attention to
the boiling point if we represent the
network of influence across regions as a
matrix encoding the correlation strength
for each pair that would be panel II
what we see is that communication
dynamics transition from a hierarchical
structure where a few regions dominate
the flow to a horizontal structure where
all regions are driving each other so
this is the method and there is a 30
page long supplementary material
document into the paper where you can
check all the details because obviously
there's a lot of parameters that you can
adjust here and I already anticipated so
if you're welcome to check it out if
you're so inclined but so and I already
anticipated the main conclusions that we
drew from these but now i'm going to
show you what the sum of the data
actually looks like and we analyzed five
datasets in the paper i'm going to show
you only data about three these are
three of the five datasets that we
analyzed the first to correspond to
political mobilization so there would be
examples of the sort of collective
dynamics that sociologists have been
interested in analyzing for over a
century and then the third figure
corresponds to the announcement of the
acquisition of motorola by google which
sort of came by surprise and people
couldn't anticipate it and its data say
that we use as a comparison benchmark to
the more endogenously driven
datasets that relate to political
protest and we obtain this time series
by sampling Twitter looking for messages
that contain relevant hashtags which is
why as I mentioned before the method
only applies with the benefit of
hindsight and so if we could find a way
of identifying relevant hashtags before
the weekend relevant you that's when
this too could be used to try to
anticipate events but we haven't found a
way of doing that yet and so what the
blue line captures here are changes in
the characteristic temporal scale which
as I said before we define in terms of
maximizing information flow and the Red
Lion tracks volume for reference the red
vertical bars correspond to the onset of
the main social events so this would be
protests or the sudden announcement of
the acquisition and the gray body in the
case of the Brazilian data said refers
to a smaller protest that was organized
before the big one so what you can see
is that there is a difference between
the first two panels and the third in
the first to the temporal scale that
maximizes information flow which in this
case it is expressed in minutes goes
down as we approach the mobilization day
in the third dataset it remains constant
until the big media announcement is made
so again one of the important things
that we show in the paper which is also
sort of subtle is that this decrease in
that important skill does not result
from increases in volume that would be
trivial but from increasing levels of
coordination across all time series and
this is something that you can see more
clearly when you look at the matrices
that encode pairwise correlations and so
here what we have on the vertical axis
is a measure that we use to summarize
how hierarchical or horizontal those
networks of influence are as time goes
by we reorder the matrices that are
geographical areas are ranked according
to the number of times that they are
dominant over the rest of the areas and
then we take the ratio between the sums
of the matrix elements in the lower and
upper triangles and so essentially this
measure quantifies the state of the
system along the continuum that goes
from hierarchical to the centralized
communication and the way in which these
parameter works is that as it gets
closer to one then
network is more horizontal or more
disordered and so that means that there
are more regions that are driving other
regions what you can see in the figure
is that communication becomes
progressively the centralized in the
case of the protests but there is no
evidence of such gradual progression in
the case of the acquisition data
although after the announcement you also
see an increase in overall driving
dynamics and what the matrices do
essentially is to zoom into specific
data points in this progression so that
you can actually see what the networks
of influence look like two points before
and after the collective event so what
are the main takeaways of these research
well first we show evidence that the
emergence of collective phenomena can be
characterized by a double transition a
transition in the timescales from slow
to fast in a transition in the patterns
of directional influence from
hierarchical to horizontal and these two
things are related right we also show
that decreasing time scales are proxy to
increasing levels of internal
coordination again the decrease does not
result from higher volumes of
communication which intuitively but also
trivially go up as collective events
like a protest gets closer but from the
increasingly higher synchronization of
all the time series which starts with
start beating with the same tempo and
finally we also offer an alternative
approach to the analysis of spatial
diffusion that does not assume that
regions play the same role all along
some regions might start leading the
process but at later stages they might
in fact start following other regions
and this is something that you can only
see when you track changes over time all
right now there's obviously many more
questions that we did not consider in
this paper in that we would like to
consider in the future for instance it
would be interesting to analyze the
properties of those networks of
influence and see if we can identify say
structural hubs it would also be
interesting to identify the factors that
shape the influence pathways that we map
so we map those pathways but we don't
explain them and it would also be
interesting to see
the same method could be applied to
different partitions not geographical
thats a demographic and although this is
contingent to the existence of
appropriate data we haven't been able to
find a proper data to test this idea
okay so we feel that we learned
something interesting about the dynamics
of the centralized communication there
was also these other questions on the
background of our work that we didn't
manage to answer again we didn't intend
to answer the question we knew would be
very difficult to give an answer to that
but we still think it would be nice if
we could and that is the question of
whether we can use measures of
coordination and distributed
communication to anticipate the
emergence of collective action and so
essentially this would imply shifting
metaphors of opinions as thermostats
that are adjusted when the temperature
changes to the analogy of early warning
systems that is common in disaster
prevention and obviously the goal here
would not be to prevent people from
organizing a protest which is a
legitimate goal but to be able to
strengthen the accountability loop
between citizens with the preferences
and their demands and the
representatives because Indian
strengthening that loop is what
democracy is all about polls and surveys
have been the main tools to monitor what
the public wants and feed that
information back to decision-making into
policy debates and we think that social
media might offer another channel to
enforce that accountability loop and
identify changes in collective attention
and ultimately opinion formation again
finding a way to do that is not trivial
and I'm pretty sure that is not more
difficult than building the self-driving
car that which Duncan was talked about
this morning and when I just show you is
a first step is an example of how we
started to think about the methods that
might help us advance in that direction
but there's a lot of work to be done
still and there's still one more
question that remains and that is do we
really need six physicists and one
sociology's to write this paper I don't
know but what I do know is that the
research that resulted from this
collaboration
was better than it would have been had
we worked on our own even though these
implied for some of us to be pushed
outside of our comfort zones like pretty
far but from my perspective I think I
really gain insights about social change
and the dynamics that important dynamics
of which sociologies haven't really
thought too much about so yes there are
still many open questions on the table
but looking back I think it's pretty
obvious that digital technologies in
social media in particular have allowed
us to move faster in the last few years
and in the previous century of
collective behavior research and so I
think Todd would be very happy with the
progress made since he wrote about those
statistics of conversation that he
wanted to compile I don't think we have
managed to come up with better metaphors
than those that he and his
contemporaries used but we have managed
to impart some of those metaphors and
get a better sense of the forces that
drive collective behavior and by
extension social change and so we now
know the time and scale matter the
dripping of information through networks
is not constant but instead it responds
to correlations in our communication
activities that get amplified in non
intuitive ways it's so that's why the
analysis of large scale coordination and
synchronization is important to
understand collective behavior we also
know that there are many sources of
complexity in networks for which we need
new metrics and we also need to come up
with alternative ways of summarizing
large-scale network data the usual
metrics that we social scientists have
been using for decades are not enough
anymore and also we have come to realize
that we need to reformulate individual
level mechanisms used in theoretical
models of social influence and contagion
as some of the talks this morning also
mentioned essentially to make them more
attune to what we observe in empirical
data for instance these temporal
correlations that are of which I just
talked about on the aggregate level and
I'm finishing up more generally one
thing that history tells us is that for
good ideas to thrive you need to support
the support of institutions but also
that the boundaries those institutions
impose a knowledge often constrain
innovation and fresh thinking right the
Social Sciences had a hard time
finding a space at the university system
those in charge of its governance were
for a long time relaxant to embrace an
emergent discipline and many teaching
and research institutions were created
to fill that intellectual space and
since I'm staying at the women's faculty
club I feel sort of obliged to mention
that women also played a crucial role in
that process I wish there were more
books written about them and so key
players include Jen whale in france and
beatrice webb in England who contributed
to the foundation of LSC the London
School of Economics and they were
central in the fundraising efforts that
made those institutions possible and
ultimately allowed the consolidation of
the field and I think that what we now
call computational social science for
lack of a better term might also be in a
similar position in the sense that it's
still it still needs to break free from
traditional ways of organizing knowledge
but it also needs to institutionalize
that some systematic progress can be
made and with these undone